Delmas shows saying that there are no
proven effective therapeutics to be had
for the new coronavirus efforts are
focused on detection and containment a
vaccine is still at least 12 to 18
months away as the corona virus pandemic
escalates knowing we have such a long
wait until we can immunize it can be
pretty scary
the corona virus that causes covert 19
is a new virus and attack cells in a new
way so we need a new drug to tackle it
that said there might already be a drug
to use we just don't know yet using pre
approved drugs is the best strategy in
the short term to help people as others
develop maybe more sophisticated
targeted approaches say with a vaccine
or with drugs that target the virus but
that could take months if not years
professor Nevin Croghan works with an
international team of scientists that
have identified pre-existing drugs with
the potential to fight the corona virus
what we've noticed here is that this
virus in a very interesting way is
coming in and essentially hijacking you
know all the major kind of biological
processes in the cell in a very
fascinating way so it's getting its
fingers and pretty much all the major
machinery in ourselves so the virus
needs our cells and our genes and
proteins in order to live and replicate
and infect ourselves so the question is
what are those proteins as we generated
this map this blueprint where we're
essentially looking for all the human
proteins connected to the voller
proteins we identified 332 of these
human proteins through this study and
predicted drugs or compounds that would
come and bind to and inhibit these human
proteins so one of the the 69 that we
predicted to bind at least one of these
332 proteins
27 of which are fda-approved drugs and
the rest are in clinical trials are
being looked at pretty clinically the
logic here is if we do get a hit on one
of these drugs we can go and look at one
of these drugs in more detail and then
see what other drugs or compounds are
similar to it so we can expand our
search space based on this initial
screen
at the end of the day which will give us
hopefully a higher likelihood of success
give us a sense of why it's easier to
use you know an old drug I think about
average it takes eight nine years to get
a drug into a person the big reason for
that length of time is that you have to
go through toxicity trials but if you
focus on on drugs or compounds that have
already passed that barrier you know you
can more quickly expedite a particular
drug or compound into a person to target
this virus and a lot of times that's not
done this kind of drug repurposing one
of the reasons is financially related
compound companies have patents for
specific compounds or drugs and if
another company finds that oh this drug
could be used for another disease well
the original company will get all the
financial benefit from that okay so
there's not a people don't look at those
that in that way that much but of course
now everybody just wants to solve this
particular problem and I would say one
of the classic examples of drug
repurposing is viagra it was initially
used to treat heart pain and then it was
realized there were other beneficial
effects associated with it we've been
thinking about this for some time and
obviously now with this sense of urgency
has really allowed us to expedite this
particular vision and test it
you